ONE WORTH YING.
>> Dana: STA BY.
THANK YOU  MUC
WANTO BRINGN MIAE
ALN WHO SERVED ON PRIDENT
SH'S NATIONASECURITY COUNCIL
AND A FORMOREIGN POLICE
ADSOR AND MAANJASOWILLSTAY WH .
YOUR STATE DEPTMENT
EXRIENCE, WALK US BEND THE
SCEN.
CHERELLE, ITTNEY'S WE,
THKED LOT OF PEOE ANMORE
MES IF SHE HADIME.
THERE WEREO MA PEOPLE BEND
THSCENES.
TELL UABOUWHAT IIS LIKE TO
HAVE O OF THESE GOTIATIONS
HIND THECENES AT THE STE
DEPAMENT.
>> THIS S REAL TOUGH
NEGOTIATIOBECAE OF WHAT ISGOING
THU.S. ANDUSSIA.
IT IS A GOTIION THE ATDEPARTME M
E MA PRIITIES OF THE U.S.
WITH RESCT TO RUSSIA, TO
SUPPORT UKRAE AND REPEL TH
SSIAINVAON OF UKRAE.
ANRUSSIA ANDUTIN WERE ING
BRITTN AS VERAGE.
IT WAS A SW TRIAL ASHE
ADMISTRAON CALLED IT.
THERWANO BAS FOR H TO
GIVEN E LETH OF SENTEN SHE
WAS GIN IN RUSSIA.
BUT BEUSE OF THE SITUAON A
THE TENSIOBETWEEN THE S. A
RUSS, THE NETIATNS WERE MUCH MO
NORMLY ARE.
THE S. AND STATE DARTMENT
D BASICALLY ENTIFIED
BRITTNEY WRONGLYETAID BY
RUSSIA AND DVE SO RD TGET
HER RELEASED.
IS A BIG SUCCESS NOT ST FOR
BRITT NE AND HER FAMILY BUT U.S.
POLICY TOWRUSSIAND SUPRTFOR UKR.
Bill: LET'S COME BACK TTHE
PHRA A BIG SUCCE
MIAEL LEN, WELCOME TO TH
CONVERSATION
WH IS UR REACTN TO THE NEWS NOT?
>> OF URSE, 'S TERRIC R
BRITEY GREINER FAMILTO
HAVE H HOME T BITTSWEET
NOTO HE PAUL WHEN CONG
HOMES WELL.
THE ADNISTTION PORITIZ
ITTN OR WHEL FAMILY.
THE OTHER ESTI FORE IS W
IS ITHAT THE RUSANWANT TO
AP FOR PAUL WHELAN ITHEY DO AT L
ERE E A VARIETOF
DISSIDENTSROUND THE GLOBE WHO
HAVE BEEHONESTLYTTACD AND
SOME CAS MURDED BY THE
RUIAN GIMENDRRESTS
ESPECILY IN GERMANY, THINK
OFNE THERE.
I WOERF THRUSSNS ARETRYING TO G
PELE RELEASED FR OTHER
PRISONAROU THE WORLD IN
EXANGEOR PAUL ELAN O
OTRS WRONGFULLY DETAIN IN
RUIA.
>> Bl: FAIR QUESTIS.
DAVIBACK TO YOON THEUOTE
BIG SUCCS.
E WHITE HOUSE D TO KNOW THWOULD
KELY PUBLIC ITICISM CAUS
TWO PELE AREOT COMING BACK
AND BAD ON A THE REPORTING
WE'VE D OV THEAST YEAR
THATAS THEIR INTT ALL ALONG.
AND TH DID NOT HAPPEN, DAVID
>> YEAH, FROM ACCOTSTHEY
WANTED A TWO F O DWHER
TH WOU GET WHEN
EINER IN EXCNGE FOR BOUT.
RUSSIAOULD NOTGREE AND WHY
IT TOOK SOONG TO G TS DEAL
DONE.
WERHEARING RURS TT THE
BRITTNEY DL WAON THE VGE
OF BEI CPLETEDONTHS O.
WHAN IS ACCUSED SPIONAGE IN RUS.
KELY ARUMP-UP CHARGE.
NO EDENCTHAT HE ACALLY
ENGED IN TT.
WAS A POLICAL PROSECUTION
BY RUSA AGN TO GET LEVERAGE.
WHAT HE ISCCUSED OF IS A MORE
SERIOUS CRE THAN BRITTNEY
GREINER THATADE  MORE
COMPCATED FOR THE U.S. TO DO
DEAL FORIM.
I TAKE THE BEN ADMINISTRATION A
STRIVE R HIS RELEASE AS
WELL A THE LIKY WI BE
SUBSEQNTRISONER EXCHGE.
>> Bill: IS A BAD DEAL, WHY DO
DEAL AALL?>> Dana: I THI ONEF T
THGS IS THATS RIWAS
SAYING SHE W THE AT TH
STATE PARTMENT WHEBOUT WAS
NVICD.
IS WAS A B SUCSSNDER THE
OBAMA ADMINISTTION
THE D.J. PRE RELSE AT THE
TIME SAID UTAS CONVICTED OCONSP
NATIONS.
CONSPING TO KI U.S. OFCERSAND EE
AN-AIRAFT MISSESND
PROVIDE MATEAL SPORT TO
FOREIGN TERRIST ORNIZAONS.
THAT'S ONE OF E THGS YOU
MEIONE MARIE, OUT PEAPS
WH HE GOES BK TO RUSHE
NOT ABLE  DO ALL OF THO
THIN AGAIN.
MAYBE THERE AROTHER BAD GU
IN T WOR.
MARI DO U KNOW WHAT IT IS LIKE
IN A SITTION LE THIS, LIKE
BRITEY HAS BEEN LD UNJUSTIFD ANN
AT CONDITIONS, BUT WE CAN
IMAGINTHEYEREN GREAT.
WHENHEY TRANSITION BACK TO T
UNED STATES, ARE YOU FAMIAR
WITHHE PCESS OF TRYING TO
GET THEMACK  TIRORMALIVES?
>>EAH, DANA, IT'S
HEARTBAKING.
WE DLT WH IS WITJASON
AND SOMEF THE HOSTAG HELD BY
IRANHEN  GOT THEM RELEASED.
IT IS PROCESS.
ESIDT BIDEN SPOKABOUT IT TODAY.
CONDITIONS SHE H HELD IN BUT
SHE HAS BEEN EXPED TO TRAUMA
AND SHE WILL HAVE A PROCESS OF
HEALG.
E WILL, HER FAMILY WILL.
A LOOF PEOPLE WHO WA THEAR
HER STORY.
WEEARD FROM TROR REED SOON
AFR HE CAME BA
IT HAS BEEA TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCEOR H AND HER
FAMILY.
GIVE HER SOME SPACAND GRACE
, YOU KN, REJOIN HAMILY,
REJOIN AMERIC SOCIETY.
I LOD WHAT HER WE SAID THI
MORNINWHEN SHE SAID WE'RE
GOING TO USEUR VOICE TO KEEP
FIGHNG FOR PAUL WHAN A THE
OTHE STIETAINED.
IS AOCACY BYHIS FAMI AND
BY BLA WEN,  SPORTS, BY
HLETES ANDPORTLEERS,
THATS WHAT HELD KE HER
STORIN TEWS.
SO ASHE COMES MEND
READJUSTS  LE, I LE THAT
HER MILY IS GOING TO KEEP
FIGHTING FORTHER DAINED AMERICA
THROUGH THIS REALLTOUGH
PROCES
>> Bl: OTHAT, HERE IS THE
COMMENT OM BRINEY'S WIFE AT
THE WHITE HOE LA HR.
TODAY MY FAMILY IS WHOLBUT AS
SO MY OTHER FAMILIES W ARE
NOWHOLE AND SO B.G. IS N
HEREO SAY THIS BUT I WL
GLADLYPEAK ON HER HALF TO SAY T
COITTED TO THE WK OF GETTING
EVERY ERICAN HOME, INCDING
PAUL, WHOSE FAMILY IS IN OUR
HEARTS TODAY
>>ill:E HEAR TT COMMENT
LOUD A CAR.
YOU TAING ABT PUTIS
TIVATIONS AND INTENTION,
THE INNTIVE HE HASOR TAKG AMERIH
THE AMERICANS W.
PAUL WHELAN IS IN A MILITARY
PRISONHE WN A LITA HOSPITA
OKS LIKE HE SPOKE  HIS
FAMI A WEEK O.HE SAID HE WAS IN
AND DOING WELL, BUT HOW DO YOU
OW ON THE OTHER END?
>> THAS DENITE THE CASE.
PUN IS, OF COUE,OLD
BLOOAND BRALLY
ANSACTIONAL.
THERE IS NO UBT THAT HE LL
COME BACK ATS WITH SE LARGE
ASIN SOME WAYS TRYING TO FREE
OTHERSROUND THGLOBE THAT FOR
NOW SEEM LIKE A BRID T FAR
FOTHUNIT STATES AND OUR ALLIES.
T I THINTHAT'S -- BIDEN IDHE IS
KE THE HARD CALLS.
I THK HE WL DEFINITELY BE TRYIN
BUT, YOU KNOW, YOURIGHT.WE'VE S
TO, FORTUNATELY,IDNAP OR
IL AMERICAN TIZEORLDWIDEIF THE O
DEAL AND OERWI SWAHOSTES
AND ISONS WITH YOU.
SO I'MLAD THE ESIDT ALSO
SAID REATHE WARNINGS ABO
WHH COUNTRIES YOARE ING TO
AROU T WORLD AND BE VERY
REFUL ABOUT WHE YOU ARE
GOING.
WOULD HAVEI WOULDN'T GO TO
RUSSIA IF WERE MANY AMICAN CITIY
>> Dan JASONCOULYOU TA
OUT THAT AS WE
YH, LTEN.THE THREAT IS RY REAL.
VLIMIRUTIN IMORE THAN A
THUG.
IS DIATOR.
HE IS EVERY GATI THINGOU
CAN POIBLYHINK OF.
M HAY ANMERICAN IS COMIN
HOME.I THINK SHWOULHAVE DIED IN
AT CUSTODY.
I INSHE LOST NINE MONT OF
HELIFEND IT IS A VERY,ERY
GH PCE TO Y AND I DO HOPE
THAT SHE WILL USE HER CELEITY
TOONTIE TO POUNDN WHELAN.
THE SQUEAKY WHEEL DOES GET A
GREA.
THERE ULD  OTHER NOTIARS
T THERE, OTHER PRISONERS IN
OTHER COUNIES AT ARE
HIGH-VALUE TGETS F PUTIN T
ING ME.
I THINTHERIS A WAY TO DO
THIS IF THE WIONTINUES TBETHERE.
>> Bil THIWHOLE EA OF
SETTING THE EXAMPLTHAT MICHAEL
WAS RERRINTO THERE.
WH YOU THINK AUT THE TALAN
FIVE FOR BE BEDAHL DO YOU
LAY THFOUNTION FOR OER WORLD LE
LEARN FROM IT?
NFORTUNATELY REPRESSIVE
REGIMES HAVE BN DOG THISOR
A LONG TIME.IRANOES, TALIB D.
RUSSIAOES GHNOW.
THERIS A LONG HISTORY  THI
THE S. IS  VERDIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCE.
WE WANT TO BRING O CIZENS
HOME.
THEYESER TO COME HOME WHEN
THEYRE CHARGED AND SENNCED
IN WAYTHAT DON'T FLOW THE
RULE OF LAW.
NOTABLY THE U. DIDT CHANGE
ANY FOIGN POLICY.
I'SUREUSSIA WOULD HA LIKED
TO TRA HER FOR T U. NOT
UKINE ANYMOR
E U.S. DIDN'T DO ANY OF THOS
THINGS
THIS IWITHIN THE REALM OF WHAT
COTRIES DEVELOPMEXCHANGE
ISONERS WITH PRISONERS.YOU DON'.
BOUT WAS BAD MAN.
HE DESERVETOERVE ERYEAR
OF H 25 YE SENTENCE.
NOBLY  DID SERVE MORE AN
HA OF THAT STENCE D HE IS
ING HOME OY BECAUSE BRTNEY
DIDN'TESER TO BE IN A
PRISON.>> Dana: THIS STS SOMETH
AT I WONDERED ABT ANI KNOWYOU W
THAT IRAZY OR WHATEVER.PRESIDENN
THINNG AUT T LEVERAGE TH
WEON'TAVE NOW TH VTOR
BOUT.YOURHOUGS ONHAT.
>>EAH, I TNK IT SHOWS ZELENSKYG
NETIATE WHEN HE FES LIKE
WE'RE ALINWITH LEVERAGWHEN
HE IS DEING TH LERAGE D
POR.
WE HAD SOMEBODTHAT PUT
WANT.
I TOOK SOMEONE IORDER TO SP.I T
WEL BE AE TO LEARN OVER TIME
ABOUT WHEN WE GET TO
NEGOATIONS, WE THEOYAL WE
INKING OF RAINE AND THE
ST, WHEN THEGET INTO
NETIATNS WITH THE RUSSNS.
I THINK ZELENSKY KNO HE HAS TO
HAVE SIOUS LEVERAGE IN OER
TO G ANYERE WI VDIMIR
PUTIN IN A NOTIATION.
D TH HAS REPERCUSSNS ABOUT
HOW MU TERRITORY HE WILL WAN
TAKE IN THE UPCOMINSPRI
OFFE